I want to start with the story itself
because Ryan you grew up in in with what
near this where this happened in this
neighborhood when I first heard about
the incident it was actually what
initially inspired me to make the film I
was I was back in the Bay Area nowhere
and that's where I was born and raised I
was back there for Christmas break
actually after my first year of film
school and it was New Year's it wasn't
you knows New Year's Eve when in a New
Year's Day and I was actually working as
a as a security guard at this at this
this big huge nightclub for this it was
like a big rave you know and I was
working the door pretty much the whole
night of New Year's Eve and into the
morning and no letter on New Year's Eve
morning like around 2:00 3:00 a.m.
actually got a car for one of my friends
who was who was riding was riding apart
that night and he told me that somebody
had been it's my head being shot at the
Fruitvale BART station and um he didn't
really it was kind of something that he
just mentioned you know he didn't really
know who it was they got shot it was
that they were no slowing down the
trains when I got back you know to back
to my house later on that day the news
started to come out that it was an
officer-involved shooting and that the
guy that got shot ended up dying in the
days following the footage came out you
know no footage that she got I saw at
the beginning of the film I'm starting
to be played on the news and on the
internet and I can just remember the
first time I saw it and she struck
something really deep in me and in
affected everybody in the Bay Area you
know as everybody saw it but I were
watching the footage and basically
seeing myself in Oscar you know I'm I
was the same age as him I was 22 at the
time as well and um you know he looked
like me were descent kind of close and I
wore his friends looked like my friends
and I just couldn't have to think of
that being myself and what would happen
if I didn't make it home to the people
that I meant that I meant the most to
you know the people that I loved the
most in the days and weeks following
people were very very angry people took
sides the situation became very
politicized you know people protested
rioted rally four years later you know
Trayvon Martin incident actually
happened right around the time I got a
call from my agent about
prove prove of station and I was like
okay it's perfect you know this is the
perfect outlet for me to kind of you
know express myself the best way I can
through my work and I remember reading
reading the script halfway through just
you know bawling my eyes out you know I
still got the script woman tears stain
pages and picking it back up
reading reading for a second time and I
calling on my agent I look I need to I
need to I need to meet this guy I have a
conversation with that with Ryan and we
met up at Starbucks you know I had a
conversation I'm in the first five
minutes in the back of my head I already
knew I was like okay cool I want to do
this just just I'm talking with him you
know he's just somebody so close in age
to myself my vision you know he speaks
from the heart the subject matter was so
close to him and myself and it was like
making a movie one of my best friends we
just instantly kind of connected so it
was a it was a no brainer for me I
really I really wanted to do it so and
then I didn't know them at the time but
you know later and him telling me that
he wrote it with me in mind it was just
like a so the biggest compliment I ever
got so it was just like it was a no
brainer for me but once I got access to
the family you know that's when they
that's when he character really you know
really opened up I was able to sit down
an interview you know Oscar's mom and
Sophina and I met Tatiana and got to
spend time with Oscars friends and you
know got to hear stories and it really
got the got to the heart of what he what
he was dealing with at that time and
then I waved that in today we've got
into the script after coming back from
the Sundance from the Sundance Film
laughs and um once we cast it I was able
to give um you know give it actors
access to the family special time with
Wanda Oscar's my little Tatiana a little
bit not not as not as much
Sophina to try my ex you know explain
that relationship to me and Melanie
now I'm so FINA Oscar were they were
like best friends um it's really hard
sometimes you know dating your best
friend because you know you wanna you
know share certain information with your
best friend you want to act a certain
way with somebody you call your best
friend that may not be the best thing
for your relationship sometimes a lot of
ups and downs so it that was like very
helpful trying to let you know figure
out their their dynamic you know all of
Oscars best friends
you know I spent a lot of time with them
you know I have barbecues playing
dominoes you know just talking here and
hearing the whole story you know just
kind of reminiscing on what Oscar used
to do and their interaction and how they
used to hang out really helped out a lot
and it reminded me and my friends back
I'm from Newark New Jersey what we used
to do you know in the back back east the
fun parts you know of acting is finding
those the layers of a person how complex
Oscar was you know especially from
talking with his family you know you got
a different perspective from everybody
everybody had a different view on who
Oscar was and who he was around them you
know and I think all of them were true
because he changed himself around
everybody just like we are as people we
kind of you know we change ourselves in
different social settings he was a
social chameleon you know we like to
call him when he was around his best
friends he was the leader you know he
was the one that you know all this boys
kind of went to for answers when he's
around his daughter he was the best dad
he can be you know when he's run Sophia
name is the best know best boyfriend
best husband best lover he could be when
he around his mom he was the best best
son he could be and it was something
interesting and kind of you know me and
Ryan tried to find the moments in those
scenes where we can you know show those
changes you know especially like in the
grocery store you know when you can you
see him go from his best friend to
customer you know to his boss you know
back to this customer back to his best
friend and he was the people pleaser you
want to keep everybody happy you know
especially the people that he really
cared about being a young
african-american male in the urban
environment um there's so many things
that you have to do almost as a survival
tactic you know people you know any
normal person you take you can talk to
five different people and get five
different stories about them but but
with but with us coming up in the urban
environments oftentimes you got to put
on our armor depending on what depending
on where you are